[Musique]
en 2023 le département déploie ses
dispositifs concrétise ses engagements
et ses ambitions retour sur le terrain
pour une année forte par les
réalisations de la
collectivité la CCI réunion et le
département signent une déclaration
d'attention pour renforcer l'insertion
des demandeurs d'emploi principalement
dans les secteurs de l'agroalimentaire
et des services à la personne nous
voulons consolider toute la
partie transformation produit avec une
industrie
agroalimentaire plus développée de façon
à donner des garanties de revenu aux
planteurs aux producteurs de la
Réunion le label 100 % la Réunion est
lancé une identité pour ces produits
cultivé et transformé à la Réunion plus
d'une cinquantaine d'artisans locaux se
sont associés à la marque inscrite dans
le plan agripays 2030 100 % réunion qui
va se décliner en 3 le label 100 %
Réunion c'est l'origine réunion le label
excellent 100 % Réunion c'est tout
simplement un produit qui a pu
bénéficier une reconnaissance nationale
internationale une médaille et puis
enfin le 100 % réunion bio vous l'aurez
compris ce sont donc les productions bio
qui sont issues de la production
rayonnaise qui seront donc mises en
avant le département est au cœur de la
59e édition du Salon International de
l'Agriculture la collectivité anime avec
les producteurs locaux le village
réunion vitrine de notre savoir-faire il
a une grande diversité de production il
y a beaucoup d'excellence c'est c'est un
premier élément c'est la reconnaissance
du travail des agriculteurs et leur
capacité à produire des produits de
qualité ce sont les premiers lauréats du
budget d'initiative citoyenne du
département sur 120 projets présentés
dans CIN grands domaines 55 ont été
récompensés le BIC a pour objectif de
rapprocher le citoyen de la collectivité
des artemental et de l'impliquer dans la
construction des politiques publiques à
travers ce budget ben les associations
on pu nous présenter leur projet et bien
évidemment ben il y a eu un vote il y a
eu des sélections et on va donc financer
leur projet pour que le citoyen soit
vraiment acteur de la vie ici à la
Réunion Elizabeth borne et plusieurs
membres du gouvernement sont en
déplacement à la Réunion ils avec le
département la création de 5 pad
supplémentaires pour 2000 places
d'accueil en faveur des personnes âgées
et handicapées la Réunion est également
le seul département d'outremè à signé la
convention d'expérimentation de France
travail c'est à la Réunion comme ça peut
être le cas dans l'Hexagone de pouvoir
cumuler le RSA avec un emploi saisonnier
vraiment l'idée c'est d'inciter au
retour à l'emploi par tout
moyen afin de renforcer ses action pour
l'accès au droit et à la prévention pour
les publics fragiles la collectivité
déploie deux nouvelles caravanes une
dédiée à la PMI et au dispositif à vif
allure pour la prévention des violences
[Musique]
intrafamiliales la collectivité a obtenu
le label terre de jeux 2024 la flamme
olympique passera donc par la Réunion en
juin prochain pour une traversée de
l'île par 100 relayeur le département
renforce son accompagnement aux sportifs
de haut niveau parle de on voit souvent
les performances on voit les médailles
et et non les Jeux Olympiques c'est
aussi le le partage la fraternité et
unir unir unir les peuples nous ici ça
va unir les cultures et donc il faut il
sera pas louper ça et voir la flamme ici
à laaréon c'est comme si qu'on on
participe au
jeux la collectivité poursuit ses projet
d'aménagement du territoire et son
programme de transition écologique un
grand chantier démarre à la rivière des
galaes avec la pose de la première
pierre d'une microcentrale
hydroélectrique aujourd'hui nous
entamons les travaux pour une trisème
micro central en rive gauche de la
rivière des Galé c'est la contribution
du département à la vocation à
l'autonomie énergétique de l'île sur
cette microcentrale nous allons produire
de l'électricité permettant d'alimenter
l'équivalent de 1000
Famille la tion et le renforcement des
liens dans la zone Océan Indien se
poursuivent une délégation s'est rendue
en namiie pour mettre en place des
échanges économiques et culturel avec le
pays une quarantaine de partenaires
s'engagent avec le département autour du
pacte territorial d'insertion avec pour
objectif de proposer une solution
d'insertion à chaque foyer bénéficiaire
du
RSA la collectivité renforce également
son partenariat avec le CHU et la CGS
réunion autour d'une convention
départementale sur le transfert
sanitaire donc on va communiquer plus et
puis on va communiquer plus auprès du
grand public et on va communiquer plus
en interne pour que chacun sache comment
on va travailler ensemble ça c'est
important coordonner pour être plus
efficace pour
l'usager le département l'État et la RS
prennent un engagement fort pour
rattraper le manque d'offre médicau
sociale pour l'accueil des personnes
handicapées la ministre met à
disposition une enveloppe de 47 millions
d'euros et le département s'engage
également avec un financement à hauteur
de 29 millions d'euros on a beaucoup
beaucoup et même pendant ces 3 jours
abordé cette question de de mobilité du
transport là aussi il y a des réponses à
apporter parce que si les personnes en
situation de handicap ne peuvent pas se
déplacer ne peuvent pas se mouvoir c'est
aussi quelque part les assigné à
résidence c'est la première édition du
dispositif révelou talent il s'adresse
aux jeunes afin de les accompagner dans
leur projet et également dans leur
participation à la citoyenneté le musée
historique de villel fête le grand 20
décembre un événement mémoriel pour
commémorer l'abolition de l'esclavage
sur ce site emblématique le musée de
villel appelé à devenir le musée de
l'habitation et de l'esclavage à La
Réunion à la rentrée 2024 lors de sa
première conférence de presse le
président du Département a présenté un
axe majeur de l'action sociale de la
collectivité la solidarité envers les
personnes les plus vulnérables le
département soutiendra la construction
des structures d'accueil pour développer
l'accompagnement médico-social de
proximité